I'm some gum Reds money's perfect so
apparently there's a third one but it's
not call the third it's cold but no one
[ __ ] knows why this is finish it and
then we can move on with our lives
I'm remembering all the [ __ ] hours I
spent with the first two but I'm like it
is it really worth it
ah got it really isn't that's the point
oh it's in Chapter now the impossible
quiz book well that should make it
easier cuz it technically has a
checkpoint then right that's the problem
with this game it doesn't have any
[ __ ] checkpoints otherwise this game
would be [ __ ] easy and that's music
and [ __ ] man what is he doing fapping
well technically he's doing it I guess
oh no that the crabs from space oh hell
no yeah what a way to kick it off I was
actually kind of cool how do you start
an impossible quiz painfully carefully
yes
which of the following is a shooting
star click clean these would ya what
time is my dentist's appointment hammer
why how the [ __ ] am I supposed to
welcome to impossible quiz eeny meeny
miny moe your mother was a big fat ho I
don't look at me like that the game said
I don't say it what do you call a female
em er a bowl bag am a madam a theme FM
FM er yep
hmm could you please point me eastwards
well I don't know do I put him on the
keyboard oh okay what is the best thing
since sliced bread now come on it's all
these horrible answers don't don't look
at me I didn't gotta make this game
turnips
I never know that is wasps it can't be
friends I didn't friend I didn't I
didn't click it
what Oh what is this that is ridiculous
illegal what is the seventh letter of
the alphabet three four five six @h Oh
at least there is some advantage of me
playing the first ones which of the
following is spent
correctly Blind Pig blend peg blipping
it's bland peg well I need to study
obviously
oh it's boom oh it is bleep oh [ __ ] one
two three four five six seven
none of the dead one counts seven we
gotta admit to ourself that we're pretty
[ __ ] smart and by we I mean I because
I did all the work I don't know where
you got the idea that you were oh oh you
cuz you're wanting your cute that's
that's cute stop it how many letters in
assassins none seven four oh four oh
[ __ ] I am gonna guess that this is I
hope it's not a vagina that's uh pretty
similar dig into mutes girl what a feat
eat for breakfast toast you gotta be
toes but its toes and toes qui salt but
bacon ah cornflake pigeon uh what what
Fork
uh okay how does this quiz to make you
feel extremely happy extremely sad
pissed off like you want to murder
somebody or sexually turned on sexually
goddammit
well piston how did this question please
press still what I press question and
that was the answer
am I supposed to click space under down
underwater oh I got it I got it yeah I
press C get it cuz its
it's like a I would and you wouldn't
understand where can you find the
meaning of life I would say a dictionary
because it has dick in it which of the
following would win a fight at what I
think a badger cuz honey daddy don't
give a [ __ ] a match a ten I don't even
know what a ten is now why the [ __ ]
would you win a match yeah that's right
this is only arousing I'm actually
surprised math hahahaha ah don't give me
the timed ones Man 2 I'm a god damn it
oh ah what do I do with this uh I still
have it ha ha ha ok so put it there I
don't understand what do I go God does
it have to have a [ __ ] bomb already
at 20 I don't [ __ ] understand you can
I pause or something so I just drag this
here oh-ho-ho so spawn so smack me
amigos what's that dorky well you're not
so [ __ ] cool are you wait your name
is swag sir mm well you win then I'm
sorry I'm sorry senpai what do you call
a baby yogurt I think this is the
correct term let's google for hot
there's no such thing as a yogurt what
tough okay that's enough Google and what
not
well this [ __ ] name can't be Peter
Jacques it is it is a young Glenn 23
there this is like an arrow so I'm gonna
know why this game tricks you man oh
then I click 23 and then I continue I'll
goddamn it okay okay I don't know if
that one counts yes it does okay cool
not smart and beautiful sorry okay which
smell lingers for
for far too long what what's a cow Pat
you really learn a lot in this game cow
patch it up I did not need to know that
I don't even know what a BOS B oh well
that's not YouTube friendly
vo but if you're not gonna have one of
the answers that don't answer the
[ __ ] question
hold it by words of wisdom which smell
lingers what ha ha ha ha ha that's funny
man
fart why is the sandwich why is your
face stupid oh come on really
what so this man his wit because you see
weed on it oh please don't press this
really you want restart the entire
reciting I think okay cool so the sign
is wet because it's seaweed on it yes
how's that even possible I mean the sea
is just a huge mass of water how could
it urinate on a beach
hey good point
oh my god what the [ __ ] Wow the
impossible quiz has sure gone downhill
deliver but for [ __ ] sake I don't know
what to do
oh come on no big deal I'll just keep
playing cuz this is fun how do you
deliver deliver Oh what oh the liver
uh-huh it's a yo blade hahaha March yeah
I knew those so there is hundred pennies
in a pine there are 100 pennies in a
Palin what a waste
no you what what occurs once in every
minute twice in every morning but never
in a thousand years
hemorrhoids swine flu Chris Locke is
licking Oh for [ __ ] sake how do I know
all these things no one knows the
answers this is just a test of fate
being on your chosen one [ __ ] but never
in a thousand years once every minute em
one time twice in every moment one too
but never in it at em what what what is
wrong with this question
you wrote it with your penis you wrote
it with your left hand Chris wrote it
did you have you wrote it with your left
hand
yes okay I'm glad it wasn't the P this
one what do you call a man with two
donkeys Edward well I don't know it well
god damn yet lucky bias oh god what the
oh well we all love spraying orange
juice I don't need P P of course
answering this question may require
bowel movements ha ha ha why why is that
a thing go away huh oh no Chris what's
gonna happen I saw what I really want to
click on I oh I need to charge it good
night sweet prince
oh hey became fabulous the root of all
evil
it's either 666 or the impossible quiz I
only have two lives it's gotta be six
six well then it's eight
I feel like it's [ __ ] they want me to
think it's the impossible quiz but the
real answer is 25.8 I know it
hiiii what I am out I have spotted you
by saying it correctly I read that as
PewDiePie people like what how's it
going bros my name is people die what
happens after pigs fly bacon goes up I
don't know what are cannibals do after
they dump their girlfriend wipe their
ass hahahahaha oh god oh my god can I do
it can I do it
oh yeah baby bartology the answer is
typecast the answer is typecast oh come
on typecast oh ha ha ha ha ha
put the Mars on oh god i [ __ ] hate
these you've piece a [ __ ]
there's our mouth sound supposed to put
on dog ah fixed it underground pipes do
I have enough time but you are fixed
why hahaha oh god that's the sky watch
them uh-oh yeah
voila what do you want what you piece a
[ __ ] it's only okay just ma'am Jason
Knight what what o Yanna federal marshal
in my junior year ago September October
November December
my mind god oh god what do I do stop
stop stop please stop
how the hell are we gonna fry all those
doggies Oh green blue indigo violet Oh
God
okay I'm gonna take that one out okay
how many keys you need to make something
unstable how many one it's their life on
Mars yes
I don't know am I supposed to [ __ ] oh no
I don't know
oh now come on how did
ah ah okay we need to find this [ __ ]
ah ah what what happened hahaha what oh
no what what happened
I broke think the game come on
it's so close I saw I was so close I
broke the game that's okay no big deal
let's do it again oh [ __ ] it's that
little [ __ ] oh yeah I was here oh it's
random there finally what we gotta shoot
him we're gonna shoot shoot him Christ
can the tentacles oh ye
oh well it's a c4 [ __ ] and I'll take it
what happens now oh no more tentacles oh
what's gonna happen in Chapter two they
would like to find out you don't have to
but you know I'm wrong it's a sky come
birthday zebras in the next one say
awesome as always of you
you